[Music]
welcome back
so today i'm going to derive the
reynolds average navier-stokes equations
for the momentum part of the navy or
stokes equations
last time we saw how we could take our
turbulent velocity field u which is a
function of space
and time and we can decompose it into a
mean flow field an average flow field
time averaged
plus all of the turbulent fluctuations
that vary in time
and when we take this this reynolds
decomposition
and plug it into the navier-stokes
equations we can get simpler expressions
or simpler equations for the mean
uh velocity field components which might
be what we care about
as engineers if i'm going to design
an aircraft or a wing i might just care
about the average drag or the average
lift
and i might not want to or be able to
afford to simulate all of these
turbulent fluctuations
i might want to average those out and
just see how they affect the mean kind
of the bulk flow quantities
and last time we did this by taking the
the reynolds decomposition this kind of
mean plus fluctuations and we plugged it
into the mass continuity equation the
divergence of u
equals zero equations this should be a
vector u
and we found by pretty simple arguments
that from
this equation the divergence of the mean
flow had to be zero
and the divergence of the fluctuating
components had to be zero
and so we're going to do the same thing
today but for the full momentum equation
up here which is a lot
hairier a lot more complicated okay so
i'm kind of looking forward to this this
is going to be one of the most involved
kind of mathematical derivations i've
done on this board
i think we're going to fill up the whole
thing so i'm pretty excited to get
started
this is you know going to be a workout
this is like going to the gym or eating
your kale
it's going to make you stronger and i
know that we all love
kale so let's jump in and i'll also
point out
i'm not actually going to derive the
entire vector momentum equation because
it would be way too big for this uh this
setup so what i'm going to do is i'm
actually going to show you how this
works for just
the u or x momentum the the first
component of this momentum equation
and we're going to plug this
decomposition into the first row of this
vector equation
and so kind of in components the
equation i'm going to solve or write
down
is u sub t this is little u uh the first
component of the velocity field
plus and this convection term we can
essentially write this
as u partial partial x
plus v partial partial y
plus w partial partial
z or z depending on which side of the
pond you're on
all of that applied to little u equals
minus partial partial x of of
p okay minus partial p
partial x plus 1 over
the reynolds number the laplacian
of the first component of u so del
squared of little u here so
i'm just solving this for the x
component the first component of the
momentum equation of my navier stokes
that's just the first row of this vector
equation i've written down here
and we are going to plug in the reynolds
decomposition we're going to plug in
this expression here for all of the
terms expand it out
and we're going to time average and see
what terms drop out we're going to see
if we can get a simplified expression
just in terms of the mean flow great
okay so let's do it
um can't stall when you're deriving the
rand's equations
so for u sub t little u is
u bar the average u plus u prime so this
is and i'm going to give myself a little
place to work here so right here
so i have u bar sub t
plus little u prime sub t and subscript
here is going to be
a partial derivative with respect to t
okay good plus now every single one of
these terms this
u partial partial x is really going to
be big u bar
uh plus you know partial partial
sorry let me slow down this is u
partial u partial x plus v partial u
partial y
plus w partial u partial z
and so for this u and this u i'm going
to be plugging in
uh u bar plus u prime
okay good and i'm going to get a bunch
of cross terms just like when you
multiply polynomials
x plus y squared you get the cross terms
we're going to get a bunch of cross
terms here this is going to be the
nastiest part of the expression
so let's try this out and let's hope i
can get this right so this
is
u bar u bar sub x uh that's just partial
with respect to x
plus u bar little u prime
sub x plus uh
little u prime u bar sub x
plus little u prime little u prime sub x
that's what i get if i take u bar plus u
prime and i plug it into this first term
u bar plus u prime
prime partial partial x of u bar plus u
prime
and i do the same thing for the second
term and the third term okay so now i'm
going to have
plus v bar
u bar now it's a derivative with respect
to y
plus uh v bar little u
prime sub y plus
okay uh plus v
u bar u bar uh good
plus little v prime u
bar sub y plus little v prime
u prime sub y this is a this is
hard to keep all of this uh going so
please you know follow along and
yell through the screen if i get
something wrong
okay plus now we have to do for the the
w component
and i'm hoping i can just do this by
pattern matching w bar
u bar sub z plus w bar
little u prime sub z plus little w prime
my fluctuations in the w direction
u bar z plus little w prime
little u prime sub z that's just my
convection term
and now i have uh these last two terms
my pressure gradient and my viscous
diffusion
so that's a little bit easier and i'm
going to say all of this stuff
equals equals
and it equals um minus
p bar x minus p
prime x
plus 1 over my reynolds number
del squared of u bar
plus 1 over my reynolds number del
squared of u prime
okay that is step one
so step one is to take my reynolds
decomposition
plug it into the x component of my
momentum equation and this is
all of the terms that i get but
fortunately
a lot of these terms are going to die
really really quickly okay so they were
not meant
for this world so this u bar is
by definition we've averaged time out
this does not vary in time so when i
take its partial with respect to time
that's zero and now the next step
is essentially we're going to time
average this entire equation we're going
to time average every single term in
this equation
and we're going to use these identities
here to kill as many terms as possible
okay so uh and there's two
equations that i'm going to use
extensively i'm going to use this one
and this one and i guess i'm also going
to use this one
well i'm using all of them to be honest
uh i guess i'm using all of these so
the time average of this entire equation
is the sum
of the time averages of every piece
that's this term
anytime i see a loan u prime and i time
average it
i can kill it even if it has a partial
derivative
because the time average of a partial
derivative
is the partial derivative of the time
average now
you're going to have to take your time
and convince yourself of these last two
just you know get a big sheet of paper
and try to work this out and convince
yourself that these two
are true but it allows me to kill this
term when i time average
and when i time average my u bar u bar x
nothing changes because the time average
of a time average is just the same time
average so this is unchanged
this is unchanged uh any term
that has one average component and one
fluctuating component
when i time average it it is
the product of the time averages and
the time average of u prime x is zero so
this term is zero this term is zero
all of the terms that have a single
fluctuating component
are zero which is huge we just killed
like half of our terms
uh my pressure prime fluctuation is
going to die out when i
average my laplacian of u prime is going
to die out when i average
and these become average average average
so this is my time averaged
reynolds averaged navier stokes equation
for the first component
of my of my momentum equation so right
off the bat i've
eliminated most of the terms i just have
a few terms left
and so i'm going to group those kind of
over here
and we're going to see if we can
simplify even more okay
so let's do that and i want to make sure
to kind of get this right this is really
important so over here i'm going to
write
that i have u bar u bar x
i'm gonna first group all of my average
terms all of my mean flow terms
uh plus v bar u
bar y plus w bar
u bar z or z
plus all of my fluctuating components
plus
uh little u prime little u prime
x time average plus v
prime u prime y time average
plus w prime u prime
z time average okay these are all of my
turbulent fluctuating components
notice these didn't go away this is
actually troublesome i wanted an
equation
just in terms of mean flow components
but i have these pesky
turbulent fluctuations here and these
are not zero the average of products of
primes are not zero
very important i should put that here uh
u prime squared
average is not zero super important
okay again convince yourself that this
is true these are essentially the
variances of the turbulent fluctuations
the average turbulent fluctuation is
zero
the variances are absolutely not zero
they're they have variance that's the
definition of
uh of turbulence pretty much okay and
then there are two more terms
this equals uh my pressure
gradient minus p bar x
plus 1 over the reynolds number of the
laplacian of
u bar so this is a much much simpler
equation
right off the bat there is no time
varying term
this doesn't vary in time these are all
average to quantities so
if i knew what these uh turbulent
fluctuations were
i could solve for my mean flow variables
and i could get my average drag or
average lift on my wing
okay but these quantities here
are a real pain these are called
reynolds stresses or they're related to
reynolds
stresses because they kind of have the
units
of a stress and i'll i'll get to that in
a minute but what we're going to do now
is we're going to try to simplify
these three terms and make them a little
bit easier to work with
so this is kind of step two we killed a
bunch of terms and we grouped them
now step three is i get to simplify this
using essentially a chain rule identity
so i'm going to do that now
it really makes my life a lot easier so
please bear with me
okay so down here we're just going to
try to simplify those
terms and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to say
i have u prime u prime
x that's this term i'm going to have
v prime u prime y
and w prime u prime z
of course time average all of them and
i'm going to set these each
equal to something where the second term
is going to add up to zero so
i'll just show you so this is um
partial u prime partial uh u prime u
prime partial x
all of that time averaged minus uh
u prime partial u
prime partial x again all of that time
average
sorry this is getting a little crowded
this is just the chain rule if you take
this term partial u prime squared
partial x then essentially it is
2 u prime partial u prime partial x
that's 2 u prime u prime partial x
so these are equal and if i move this
over here i get two of them
and that's just the chain rule of this
guy same thing i can chain rule this
one and i get that that is the partial
of v prime u prime uh with respect to y
time average minus
uh i guess this would be a u
prime partial v prime partial y
time average again if i chain rule
v prime times u prime with respect to y
i get
v sub y u prime plus
u sub y v prime so if i add these up i
get that by the chain rule
and then the last one similarly sorry
this is just uh
i trust me it's going to make our lives
easier and it's going to make it
much clearer what this term is the last
one is just partial
w prime u prime partial z
averaged minus i guess
u prime partial w prime partial
z averaged but here's where it gets kind
of interesting
if i take these three terms here
the u prime partial u partial x
u prime partial v partial y u prime
partial w partial z all of this
added up because we're adding these
three up
all of this added up is u
prime times
the divergence of vector u
prime little component u prime
times the divergence of the vector u v
w and we know from the last lecture
that the divergence of the fluctuations
is zero so this whole term equals zero
these three terms add up to zero so the
sum of these
is the sum as the same as the sum of
these so that's where it gets really
nice is i'm going to
uh simplify this
and i'm going to write down that this uh
these three terms here
are just uh u prime
u prime average
partial partial x plus
u prime v prime average
partial partial y plus
partial partial z of u
prime w prime that's what these three
terms become
and i still have my other terms i still
have my
u bar u bar x plus
v bar u bar y plus
w bar u bar z
and all of this equals minus p bar x
plus one over reynolds number of
laplacian
of u-bar this should be a big u whatever
it doesn't matter
u-bar okay good so now we have
finally arrived at the kind of
expression i wanted
which is we took the reynolds
decomposition
we plugged it into the navier-stokes
equations the first component only
here and i time average to kill most of
the terms
we collected the terms that stayed alive
here
and we have these pesky terms that
contain just these fluctuating turbulent
components
we use some math identities here to
simplify we basically use the divergence
free part of the fluctuation
components to get this final expression
this
is the reynolds average navy or stokes
equations
at least the first component of it you
could do this for the second component
for
a little v sub t the third component for
little w sub t
and you would get three of these big
equations
now here's the part i really wanted to
get to which
is this equation is
almost exclusively in terms of mean
variables
averaged variables the bulk properties
of the flow that i want
to know about like my average drag and
my average lift are going to be computed
from
but i have these pesky
terms here these are called the reynolds
stresses
these are my reynolds
stresses and they stress us all out
in turbulence modeling in fact it's
literally the u
prime u prime bar that's a reynolds
stress u prime v
prime bar is a reynolds stress and u
prime w prime bar is a reynolds stress
because when you take their gradient or
their partial derivatives with respect
to space
you get a term that has the units of
force
per volume just like these uh stresses
so you can kind of move these terms down
here and they act to
force the the mean flow variables kind
of how a stress would
and so the whole game of turbulence
modeling the whole
uh strategy of reynolds average navy or
stokes and other turbulence modeling
is to try to approximate these
quantities which depend on the
turbulence fluctuations i need
to know my u prime of space and time
this is a mess to compute
can i approximate these reynold stresses
in terms of the mean flow
and it's only going to be an
approximation it is not going to be
exact we're going to lose information
but if i can approximate these reynolds
stresses in terms of these mean flow
quantities
then i have a chance of actually solving
this for u bar
v bar and w bar which tells me a lot
about the bulk properties of my
engineering flow
okay so we're going to go way more into
depth kind of deriving some of these
closure models
looking at what are some of the models
for these turbulent fluctuations of
these reynold stresses
in terms of these big bulk mean flow
properties
and then we're going to look at how you
can start using deep neural networks and
machine
learning to get these closure models
from data
so that's all coming up it worked